it's that time again to talk to you
about the latest games in new releases
and this week those terrorists are back
and you get to save the day with lasers
call of duty advanced warfare comes out
with some updated weaponry including
laser and energy directed weaponry use
your future weapons to take down the KVA
with guns and general badassery so that
kevin spacey will tell you how impressed
he is with you just like in your dreams
cod unveils on the 4th also this week
you're in the hot seat managing more
than 50 countries across the world
including all of Europe's biggest leads
with football manager 15 you decide who
plays and who sits on the bench and
you're in total control of tactics
teamtalk substitutions and pitchside
instructions as you follow the match
live but what's new this year well
Movember of course many of your favorite
characters will slowly grow mustaches
over the course of the November month
sweet the swapper cloned itself to Wii U
this week and if you never gave it a
play before there's no better time use a
device to make endless clones of
yourself to get into precarious spaces
and explore a space station the puzzles
are really enjoyable to figure out and
the whole stations kind of got that
Metroidvania vibe going on so it's good
clone killing fun start swapping on the
6th all you need is the Hercules adapter
which is a USB cable connects to a
standard quarter-inch output jack pretty
much any electric and bass guitars it's
cheaper than lessons and you'll be more
motivated because you look like a rock
star slap at a bus November fourth
finally the brand new remake of the
beloved Binding of Isaac the rebirth
comes out and it's the same randomly
generated action RPG you love but with
new chapters new characters and a new
secret ending fight all sorts of gross
creatures from the depths of Isaac's
basement find hundreds of items that
each come with their own individual
effects master a satisfying combat
system that deals up heavy damage
monsters are vicious music is driving
bosses or difficult jokes are funny what
the hell else do you want
is a win for further details visit
gamespot com release dates are based on
retailer listings and are subject to
change see you next week